You know what’s fun about summertime?
Going swimming.
You know what’s not so fun?
Catching diseases from the germ infested water.
Hey guys, Chastity here for DNews.
Summer is coming.
As the temperatures warm up, many of you will
be hitting the beaches or hanging out at the
pool.
But something dangerous lurks in those waters.
I’m not talking about sharks.
Chances are, you’re swimming in germs.
In the U.S., oceans are contaminated with
oil, sewage, and storm runoff containing parasites,
bacteria, and viruses.
These can cause a number of diseases.
According to the EPA, up to 3.5 million people
become ill from contact with raw sewage from
sanitary sewer overflows each year.
Polluted beach water-related illnesses include
stomach flu, skin rashes, pinkeye, respiratory
infections, meningitis, and hepatitis.
Legionnaire’s disease can be contracted
by inhaling contaminated mist or vapor.
This form of pneumonia is a common waterborne
infection that causes high fever, coughing,
and muscle aches.
Health officials recommend waiting at least
72 hours after a storm before going into the
ocean.
Within those 72 hours, coastal waters are
polluted with runoff that may contain sewage
from sewer pipes and manholes.
According to a study conducted by the Santa
Monica Bay Restoration Project, there is an
increased risk for swimmers within 400 yards
of a flowing storm drain.
So watch where you swim.
Surfers and divers are at greater risk of
getting sick from infested water than swimmers.
Staphylococcus aureus is a common bacteria
found on the human body, but a cut or a wound
in the skin can open it up to a staph infection.
Surfers are especially prone to staph infections
and are at risk of the more resistant strain,
MRSA, especially if they have wounds that
are not properly treated.
The results can be life-threatening.
Orange County surfer Timmy Turner nearly died
after a staph infection attacked his brain.
Water went up his nose during a stormy day,
which started off with sinusitis and an ear
infection and lead to something much worse.
Last Christmas, former surf champion Gary
Ault died from a staph infection, after surfing
in San Diego two days after a rainstorm.
Swimming in lake water comes with risks, too.
Last summer, 70 people who swam at an Oregon
lake caught norovirus, a virus that causes
inflammation of the stomach and large intestine
lining.
More than half were children between the ages
of 4 and 10.
Officials believe a swimmer with norovirus
infected the water with vomit or diarrhea,
which the other swimmers then swallowed.
Gross.
While that may have been an extreme isolated
incident, lakes and streams are still in danger
of pollution from sewage, livestock waste,
and improperly functioning septic systems.
Also, when entering the water, you should
look out for blue-green algae, also known
as cyanobacteria.
Swimmers and water skiers may experience stomach
pain, vomiting, diarrhea, or an allergic reaction
after contacting water with this toxic blue-green
algae.
So I’ve scared you off from open water,
but surely swimming pools and hot tubs must
be safe, right?
They’re chlorinated!
Sorry guys, but the chlorine used to disinfect
pools does not kill all germs instantly.
According to the CDC, there are germs tolerant
to chlorine that can take anywhere from minutes
to days for chlorine to kill them.
If you swallow or breathe in even a little
water with these germs, you can catch a Recreational
Water Illness, or RWI.
RWI’s include gastrointestinal, skin, ear,
respiratory, eye, neurologic, and wound infections.
But the most common RWI is diarrhea.
Cryptosporidium, a diarrhea causing parasite,
can survive for days in well-maintained pools.
Reported crypto cases went from just over
3,000 in 2004 to 10,500 in 2008.
That’s an increase of over 200 percent!